Hello world.
It's a Raj and quantum computers.
How do they work and
how do they benefit AI?
Let's talk a little bit about the theory
and then we'll build a very simple
quantum algorithm.
By the way,
the machine that you're
using to watch this video,
whether it's a laptop or a phone,
is an example of a classical computer.
It's a general purpose machine.
We can code up an algorithm,
give it some quality data,
and theoretically it can
accomplish pretty much any task.
We'd like streaming live video,
creating immersive three
dimensional environments,
eliminating existential dread.
Actually it doesn't do that yet,
but at their core,
all classical computers do something
really basic under the hood.
Behind every software application is
a series of simple math operations.
Any task we want to perform on a computer
like booking a flight or playing a
game is translated into a
string of ones and Zeros,
which act as input that is processed by
an algorithm which then outputs a new
string of ones and Zeros,
algorithms in all their complexity.
In the end just manipulate strings of
bits where each bit is either a one or a
zero.
We use ones and Zeros because there a
way of representing information such that
it can only be in one
of two different states.
Computers run on electricity de when a
computer wants to send information from
one place to another,
it sends pulses of
electricity over a wire.
Computers use transistors that can either
be closed so that a current flows or
open,
which means there isn't a current,
both states are represented
using either a one or zero.
They're like light
switches either on or off.
So when these ones and
Zeros are strings together,
they can represent any number or letter
using binary code computers you circuits
called logic gates that are composed of
transistors connected together and they
compare patterns of bits to turn them
into new patterns of bits using simple
arithmetic, hard drives,
store ones and Zeros.
By changing the magnetic poles
of small parts of a metal disk.
Positive and negative charges
are represented by ones
and Zeros respectively.
So computers do these
two things really well.
They store numbers in memory and can
process these numbers with simple math
operations. I'm just like,
you vote for Sirajuddin?
Let's make binary great again.
In 1965 the founder of Intel Gordon
Moore predicted that the number of
transistors per square on integrated
circuits what continue to double every 18
months.
So far it's proven to be true,
but there is a coming plateau
and transistor density.
We can only make them so small
before the laws of physics stop us.
The idea of quantum computing
is a potential solution
and that's why interest in
it has increased in recent years.
The word quantum in physics means the
minimum amount of any physical entity
involved in interaction.
So a photon is a single quantum of light.
For example.
That's its real scientific definition,
but it's also used colloquially sometimes
to mean the opposite like quantum leap
or buy anything.
Deepak Chopra says
the Aficionados in the
world of quantum physics,
I have somehow hijack the
word for their own use.
Quantum physics deals with the world of
atoms and the subatomic particles inside
of them. It's really a bad ass
because on the atomic scale,
the laws of classical
physics no longer apply.
Richard Fineman put it best when he
said things on a very small scale,
behave like nothing you have any direct
experience about or like anything that
you have ever seen.
Tiny particles like electrons and photons
can take on several states at the same
time that a larger scale
would be mutually exclusive.
They can be in several places at once
or exhibit two kinds of polarization.
At the same time,
we're not able to see this super
position of different states because it
disappears once someone
tries to measure it.
Nobody really knows how that happens,
but it does.
We can use this concept of super position
to free computers from having binary
constraints.
Quantum computers use
particles magnetically
suspended in near absolute zero
temperatures to represent not bits but Q
bits instead of representing either one
or zero. They can also represent
them both simultaneously. Okay,
so you might be thinking big deal.
Could you just achieve super position on
a classical computer by just using two
ordinary bits at the same
time? No need for a cubit? No,
because there's more to quantum
physics then just super position.
There's also the idea of entanglement.
If we have a system of
more than one cubit,
these particles are not independent
of each other. They're entangles.
So in a system of two cubits,
the outcome of one cubit tells you what
you will see when you measure the other
cubits.
Particles can be entangles even if
they are separated in space by huge
distances.
Einstein called entanglement,
spooky action at a distance.
That's my Einstein voice.
What that means is that you can't just
describe a system of several cubits using
descriptions of individual cubits.
You have to describe the
correlations between two cubits,
and as you increase the number of them,
the number of correlations
grows exponentially.
So for a system of just 300 cubits,
you'd need more numbers than there
are atoms in the visible universe to
describe.
Think about that for a second.
So because we can't just write down
the info contained in a system of a few
hundred cubits using classical bits,
maybe a computer running on these
cubits can perform tasks that classical
computers couldn't achieve.
That's why people think quantum
computing holds a lot of promise.
So let's build a simple quantum algorithm
in python using IBM's quantum API to
learn more. You can sign up for access
to their API easily on their website.
Then download the Sdk to use it in python.
After we import it,
we're going to build the
Deutsche Jasa Algorithm,
one of the first quantum
algos to be proposed.
We are given a quantum computer known as
an oracle that implements some function
f.
It takes end digit binary values as input
and produces either a zero or one is
output for each value.
The function is constant zero on
all inputs or one on all inputs.
It could also be balanced so it returns
one for half of the input domain and
zero for the other half.
The task is to decide if f is constant
or balanced by using the oracle.
First,
we'll initialize a quantum program object
with a quantum and classical register
holding three bits.
The program lets us manipulate quantum
circuits and each circuit has a set of
data registers,
will apply what's called a Hattah
marred gates to every cubit.
So now all the possible states
are equally likely to be observed.
For every possible state
will apply the Oracle.
In our case the oracle is a balanced
function. Then we'll apply the HK two,
all the cubits once more and
that's it for our algorithm.
For a constant function,
we can expect a 100% chance of observing
all zeros and for balance function.
We can expect anything else.
This shows that a black box problem
can be solved efficiently by a quantum
computer with no error,
whereas a classical computer would need
way more queries to the black box to
solve the problem. I just sacrificed
relationships for greatness.
These hands have yet to create their
masterpiece intelligence Zuma class.
So there are three takeaways here.
Quantum is the study of physical
phenomena that happened at the atomic or
subatomic level.
Quantum computing takes
advantage of quantum physics
to allow for more efficient
algorithms and cubits.
Not Bits are the fundamental
unit of quantum computing
capable of simultaneously
representing both a one and a zero. The
wizard of the week is no one would doubt.
The challenge was to build
a queue learning bond and
you know he used care Os.
It trained a DQ learner in the carpool
environment until it was able to
successfully balance itself.
Loved animation at the end,
great work and run around his fee. John
Won. He use tensor flow to build a Dq,
enter the gate breakout with no
high level raptors. Nicely done.
The coding challenge for this week is
to try your hand at building a simple
quantum algorithm using IBM's Api.
Details are in the read me posts or
get help link in the comments and I'll
announce a winner next week.
I hope you like this video.
Please subscribe for
more like it if you did,
and for now I've got a quantum teleport,
so thanks for watching.